hi everyone and welcome my name is
saldina i am a software engineer
and i make programming related videos on
code beauty youtube channel
and in this video i want to talk about
oop so
object oriented programming this course
will start on a beginner basic level
and then as the course progresses we
will see some of the more
advanced concepts i will explain those
advanced concepts and i will show you
how you can implement
all of those concepts in code you can
find the full content of this course
in the description of this video so make
sure to check that out
and then if you want to see some
different examples if you want to learn
more c plus and you want to upgrade your
knowledge
i have a lot more videos like this one
on my channel so i invite you to visit
code beauty youtube channel
and i'm going to see you there in some
other video so let's start
with this video so the first thing that
i want to explain is what
is oop what is object oriented
programming
oop is programming paradigm which means
that
it is a set of rules and ideas and
concepts it is basically a standard in
programming
that we use to solve a specific type of
problem
now besides object-oriented paradigm
there are other
programming paradigms as well you may
ask why
well we as humans have a lot of
different types of problems
and our computers help us solve those
different types of problems
and if one paradigm is good to solve one
type of problem for example
that does not necessarily mean that it
is good to solve
all other types of problems that we have
so
the idea behind object-oriented paradigm
is
we want to be able to represent
real-life
objects real-life entities together with
their characteristics with their
attributes and their behaviors we want
to be able to explain
those objects to our computer and to
represent those objects
in our program and that is exactly what
oop
is used for so how does this work on a
real life example let's use the example
of car
so a car as an entity in real life has
many different
attributes many different
characteristics and some of those are
manufacturer of that car so
is that car a volvo a ferrari or
a ford or some other type of car and
then that car certainly has
a collar it has price it has max speed
that that car can obtain
and many more characteristics i'm sure
that you can think of
many more characteristics of a car than
i can do
so those would be some of the attributes
and characteristics of
a car in real life and then some of the
behaviors of a car
are for example a car can drive a car
can accelerate it can
uh stop you can open the door of a car
you can tank your car so you can put
fuel in your car and then you should
also have the option to
show how much fuel that car has left so
those would be some
behaviors that car has and as i said
object oriented programming the idea of
object oriented programming
is to be able to represent that car from
real life
in your program so how do we do that how
can i represent
a real life entity like a car in my
program or
another entity like a game or a sport or
student or a book or animal you know
so the answer to this question is by
using
classes now class is very important
concept in oop
class is building block of object
oriented programming
and um a class is basically user
user-defined
data type and in order to be able to
understand what are user-defined data
types
you first need to understand what are
pre-defined data types what are built-in
data types so
data types like integer and float and
double and character
and so on and if you are not familiar
with these i am going to refer you to my
video
that i made on my channel related to
variables and
data types so just search code beauty
variables
data types and you should be able to
find that video
and then if you are familiar with these
predefined data types i'm going to tell
you that a class
is a little bit more complex data type
and in what way well let's say for
example that in your program you want to
represent
username of your user in order to be
able to do that
you will just create a variable of type
string and call it
username and you should be able to store
the username
of your user in that variable but
what happens if you want to store the
entire user
in your program that user has many more
characteristics than just username user
has
his name as well and then gender and
email address and then he has
height and width and um i'm sorry wait
he has weight and then he also has
some other characteristics and all of
these characteristics are going to be
variables that have its own type and
then
all of these variables together are
going to make one group
which will be a class that represents
your user
one thing to keep in mind though is that
you will need to store the information
that is important for your specific
program for example if we are talking
about facebook user
then height and weight of that user is
not that important
but if you are building a fitness
application then
height and weight of your user is
extremely important so you should store
the information that is important for
your
specific program so let me show you now
how we can build
a class in c plus code and the ide that
i'm using
here is called visual studio and you can
download community version of visual
studio for free
in case that you want to follow this
tutorial and type at the same time
together with me so let me show you now
how you can create a class
in c code the class that i want to
create
is called employee so let's do that now
let's create an
employee class in this program here so
the first
thing is you type class keyword
and then you give a name to your class
so i'm going to call my
employee like this
and then you use these curly brackets
and at the end of these
curly brackets you need to put semicolon
because if you don't if you forget this
semicolon you will get a compile time
error
and if i try to run this program now
that is not going to be possible as you
can see here and it says here
immediately it says
expected a semi column so you need to
put semicolon
here okay now that we have created
this employee class we see that this
class is empty
and what we need to put inside this
class here so inside these curly
brackets
because that is the body of our class we
need to put
members of this class now the members of
this class are going to be
its attributes and its behaviors so what
kind of attributes
an employee has well an employee
definitely has a name so let's put
that in so i'm going to say std
string and then name like this
okay and then employee definitely has a
company that he works for so let's add
that as well
i'm going to say std string
company like this okay and i want to
move this
uh string i'm going to include it here
so i'm going to say using
std string so that i don't need to type
it every time that i'm using string
okay and now i can remove this now it
looks much more
readable okay so so far we have added a
name
and a company for our employee and let's
add one more thing let's say that every
employee has
age so inch age we are going to
we are going to represent age as
an integer number so as you can see at
the end
of each of these attributes you put
semicolon
as well okay so far our employee has
three attributes
name company and age and you can add
many more attributes here if you want
you can add
his title you can add his email you can
add employment date his birth date
uh and so many more but i'm not going to
do that in this
situation because i don't want to add a
bunch of code that we will not be using
because i'm going to add that code as we
need it later in the program
so this class here does not represent
data this class here represents a
blueprint
so whenever you want to create an
employee this class here will serve
as a model for that employee so this
class here will say
hey your employee needs to have a name a
company name
and age so how do you create an instance
of this class how do you create an
object of this class
let's show that now so how do you create
a variable of type int for example well
you
type data type first so int
and then you give the name to that
variable so let's call it
number okay and with this we have
successfully created a variable of type
int and it is going to be the same with
the variable of type
employee so you first specify the name
of that type
and the name is going to be employee so
this here is user defined type
which is called employee
okay and then how do i want to name this
variable let's call it
employee 1 like this
and with this we have successfully
created a variable
of type employee this here is going to
be an object
of this class here so let's remove this
because we don't need it anymore
it was just for demonstration purposes
so
how do you access now these attributes
how do you access these members
of employee class well the approach
would be the following
you type the name of that object
like this and then if i put dot here
we should be able to see all of these
members here but that is not happening
so
why is that the case well there is one
rule that says that
everything inside class in c plus plus
is private by default which means that
all of these members here are private
and in order to be able to understand
this and fix the problem that we have i
need to tell you a little
story about access modifiers so in c
plus plus we have three access modifiers
we have
private we have public and then we have
protected
and let's explain now what each of these
mean well
private means that whatever is private
in your class
that is not going to be accessible
outside of your class that is basically
going to be
hidden and that public means that
whatever is public in your class
you will be able to access that outside
of your class as well so anyone else
outside of your class is going to be
able to access
public members of your class and then
protect it
is somewhere in between private and
public and it has
certain rules to it so we will be
talking more about
protected access modifier when we start
talking about inheritance
later in this course so for now you need
to remember that there are three of them
there is private there is public and
protected so in this particular
situation
one rule is that everything
inside your class is private by default
so this situation here is the same
as if we wrote it like this
okay this is just explicit way to say
hey everything beneath this private
access modifier is going to be
private so this situation is the same
as this situation now let's return our
private access modifier and let's see
how we can fix the problem that we have
and the problem is that we cannot access
these members of our employee class and
we want to do that so
let's try to change this private access
modifier with a different
access modifier let's try protected for
example
well if i try to access
these members name company and age now
if i press dot
as you can see nothing is happening so i
cannot access these name company names
if i try to type for example name
i get an error which says member
employee name is inaccessible so
protected is not helping as well
so let's try the third one let's try
public
okay and now as you can see the error
has disappeared and if i try
to do this once more we have all of
these
members name company name and age we
have all of them
here they are offered to us so that
means that
by changing this access modifier to
public we will be
able to see all of these properties here
so
let's now set the values of these
members
let's say that the name of our employee
will be for example
saldina that's my name okay
and then let's copy this two more times
like this so the company will be
let's say for example youtube and then
code beauty which is my channel let's
say that that is the company that i work
for
and then um age
okay age is an integer variable so we
are going to set it as an integer
and age is going to be 25. okay
so with this here we have created an
object
of type of type employee that object is
called
employee 1 and here we have set
values for the properties we have set
values for name
company and age of this employee object
here
but we also said that we can describe
behaviors as well
so how can we describe a behavior of an
employee
let's first think of a behavior that an
employee has
let's say for example that he can
introduce himself
so he comes to work and he says hello my
name is
so and so i work for this company and i
am
25 years old so how can we describe
that behavior in this class here well
we can describe that with a class method
and what a class method is
it is basically a function so we are
going to create a function
inside this class employee so let's do
that
i'm going to create a function of return
type
void and i'm going to call that function
introduce yourself
like this okay and then inside this
function
what i want to do is you can write hello
my name is and then you put this name
and then i work for
this company and i am 20 years old for
example
but i'm going to make it a little bit
more formal so i'm going to say the
following
c out and then i'm going to write out
name
like this okay and then let's put
name and
i'm going to add endline and then i'm
going to write out
these two informations as well so
company and then
paste here company and then age as well
okay now how can i invoke this
introduce yourself function well the
same way as we did here
i'm going to say employee and then i put
dot
and as you can see this introduce
yourself function
is available here so let's invoke that
function
like this and now we should be able to
test this so if
i run my program okay
as you can see here it says name salina
company youtube code beauty and then age
25 okay great and now if we needed to
introduce our employee five times for
example
we just copy this function five times
like this and our user is going to
introduce himself five times
and if we didn't have this class method
here
we would have to copy this code five
times so each time that we want to
introduce
our user we would have to copy this code
here
instead of doing that we can create a
class method which represents a behavior
and then we can invoke that class method
whenever we need it and if i run
this program this user should introduce
himself five times
okay two three four
and then oh sorry four and then five
okay let's now delete
this because i don't need it anymore
because i want to show you something
else
so let's say that we want to create
another employee in our program so how
would we do
that well we would use the same approach
that we had here
so employee the name of my class and
then
employee let's call it employee 2 which
is going to be the name
of the object so let's assign
the values for these attributes for our
second employee as well i'm going to say
employee two like this
and his name is going to be john for
example
like this let's copy this two more times
so company will be
amazon for example john works for amazon
and he has uh let's say
35 years like this okay
so now if i want to introduce john i'm
going to say
employee 2 dot introduce yourself
excellent so if i run this program now
as you can see here is me salina youtube
code beauty and then here is john
john amazon35 okay
now one problem that i already see here
is
this part of the code and then this part
of the code
what would happen if we wanted to create
10 more users or
100 more users we would have to repeat
this for every single user that we
create and that is not really
optimal because there is a better way
there is a better approach of
constructing our objects
and in order for you to be able to
understand this i will have to tell you
a story about
constructors so now you may wonder
salvino what is a constructor well a
constructor
is a special type of method that is
invoked
each time that an object of a class
is created so whenever you create an
object
of a class a constructor is invoked
so does that mean that here and here as
well
a constructor is invoked the answer to
that question is
yes now you may wonder okay we have not
created any constructor you must be
lying
well let me demonstrate you something
let's comment this code here
and now let's comment this code here as
well and
let's see what will happen if i run my
program
so we are not assigning any values to
the
attributes of this employee nor this
employee here so
if i run my program okay here is what
happens
as you can see this is our first user
and this here is our second user
so here we don't have anything and then
here we here we also don't have anything
and then here is a number which
i am not going to try to read okay but
basically
this here is the work of default
constructor so
what is default constructor default
constructor is a term
to describe a constructor that is
automatically generated by your compiler
so
in case that you don't create a
constructor of your own
your compiler is going to automatically
give you a
constructor which is called default
constructor
okay now let's stop this and
let's see how we can create our own
constructor because those values that
you saw
that is something that we cannot work
with i mean we don't want to work with
those values we want to use our own
values
we want to use this and this and then
this here and for our second user we
want to use
these values here so how can you create
a constructor of your own
there are a few rules when it comes to
creating constructors
there are three rules actually so the
first rule is
following we already said that a
constructor
is just a method but unlike other
methods
a constructor does not have a return
type
so let's scroll this up and
as you can see this method here
introduce yourself this method has a
return type of
void which is nothing but we still have
to specify that
but a constructor will not have this at
all
so that's going to be the first rule the
second rule is that a constructor has
the same name
as the class that it belongs to so the
constructor of class
employee will be called employee so that
is
the second rule the third rule is that
constructor must be
public now this i'm seeing as a rule at
this level of knowledge because
a constructor does not necessarily need
to be public always there are
certain situations specific situations
when you would want to make your
constructor
private but at this level of knowledge i
would advise you to make sure that your
constructors
are public because if you remember when
we talked about access modifiers and
when we said what private means
that means that everything that is
private is locked is hidden
inside your class and you most
definitely don't want to make your
constructor hidden so uh third
three rules uh the first one is that
constructor does not have
return type the second one is that
constructor has the same name
as the class so let's create constructor
of this class here
it will be called employee and i am
going to put
that constructor in this public area
because if i decided for some reason to
put this constructor
if i decided to make this private let's
do
let's make this private like this as you
can see
immediately here we get an error so our
employee one and then our
employees too this error says
employee constructor is inaccessible
and here as well because we have made
this constructor private and we cannot
access it outside of this class here and
we do not want to do that
we want our constructor to be public so
i'm going to remove this private access
modifier and as you can see this error
here has
disappeared now so the job of this
constructor here is going to be to
construct
the object of employee that means that
whenever we create
employee we want to pass these three
values here so
name company and age we want to pass
that to our constructor
here so we are going to receive that in
our
employee constructor as parameters so
i'm going to say
string name
and then string company
like this and int age
okay now that we have received these
three parameters here what i want to do
with them is i want to assign them
to these three properties here so i'm
going to say
name of my employee will be this
name here like this and then
company that our employee works in it
will be
this value here so company
and then age like this
will be whatever we passed as this
parameter
here okay and now if you look at our
employee here we have an error again
so let's check what their what that
error is it says
no default constructor exists for class
employee so what this error here means
it means that when we decided to create
our own
constructor at that moment we lost
the default constructor that was
automatically generated
for us so when you decide to create your
own constructor
you are going to lose that default
constructor and you can fix that by
either
making your own default constructor or
by
providing here these three values that
we have specified that our constructor
is going to receive
so let's do that let's provide here name
company name and age so how do we do
that well
let me show you how we can use this
constructor here
so in this line i'm going to say
that my employee 1 is going to be equal
to
and i'm going to invoke this constructor
basically so i'm going to say
hey i am invoking this constructor here
and here it expects to receive argument
list what is argument list
it is these three parameters so name
company and age so here i'm going to
pass
name which is salvina
and then company is going to be this
company here so youtube code beauty i'm
going to copy that
and then age is going to be 25
okay so with this we have successfully
constructed our employee one
object which means that i can delete
this code here
and then if we do this same for our
employee tool we will be able to delete
this code here as well so let's do that
i'm going to say
employee and then here i want to pass
these three values so name is john
okay and then company is amazon
like this and then age is 35.
excellent so i am able to delete
this as well and let's
check what is going to happen if i run
my program i'm just going to format
this so if i run my program nothing
should change
i should still be able to introduce this
user and then this user as well so let's
do that let's run our program
okay and as you can see selena youtube
code beauty
and then 25 john amazon 35.
so now we have managed to reduce the
code that we had in our main function
to only two lines per employee so
the first line is to construct that
object and then
second line is to introduce that user
and we have managed to do that
with our employee constructor which is
now doing that work of constructing the
object based on based on the parameters
that we passed to that
constructor that constructor receives
those parameters here and then
it constructs the object here it
initializes the values of that
object and then in our introduce
yourself function whatever we
invoke that function for an object of an
employee
that function is going to do this code
here so it is going to basically
introduce that
employee so i hope that this part so far
was understandable for you because
here i'm going to take a quick break and
i'm going to pause the video and then i
might be back in a couple of minutes or
in a couple of hours or even in a couple
of days but that is going to be
just a couple of seconds for you and i
want to make a transition that i never
did
on my channel i never did this on code
beauty but i'm going to do it here
and that is this transition here
hello and welcome back and let's
continue talking about
object oriented programming but before i
continue i want to make a quick
summary of the things that we have
learned so far in this course
so first i have explained what is
object-oriented programming and what is
the main idea behind
object-oriented paradigm and then i have
explained what our classes and what our
objects and how you can use those
classes and objects
in order to represent real life entities
together with their attributes and their
methods
in your programs describe them to your
computer
and then we also talked about access
modifiers so
private public and protected and then we
have seen what our constructors and how
you can create
and use constructors and now the time
has come to talk about
four most important principles four
pillars for most important concepts of
object-oriented programming
and those are encapsulation abstraction
inheritance and polymorphism so the
first one that i want to talk about
is encapsulation so what is
encapsulation
the idea of encapsulation is idea of
bundling or tying together data and
methods that operate on that
data so that they are grouped together
within a class
and why do we do this well we do this
with the purpose of preventing
anyone or anything outside of our class
to be able to directly access our data
and to interact with it and to modify it
so i am not saying that we don't want
anyone
to access our data at all i'm just
saying that i don't want that to happen
directly i don't want that other class
to be able to directly
modify and change and interact with my
data
because i want to provide my own way for
that
to happen so how do i do that how do i
provide
a way for other classes to interact with
the properties of my class
well i provide very specific public
functions
that that other class can invoke and in
that way interact with my data
so again how do you access encapsulated
properties of a class the answer is
through
its methods and these methods are very
often implemented as getters and setters
so
now i'm going to show you in code how
those getters and setters
look like and how we can modify this
program that i have here
so that we obey that rule of
encapsulation
so the first thing that i want to do
here in this program is
i want to make these three properties i
want to make them
private so i want to encapsulate these
three properties
hide them within this class so let's do
that
here i'm going to put private modifier
so this here is private access modifier
and we don't actually have to write this
because
everything that does not have a modifier
at all in
c plus plus is private by default within
a class
but i just find it more readable if i do
it this way so now
here in this private area i am going to
move these three
properties okay and then paste them here
like this and now we have hidden these
three properties
within this class called employee which
means that now we will not be able
to access these three properties anymore
outside of our class
let me just collapse this and let me
prove you what i just said
okay so if i try to access
name or company or age on my employee
object
i should not be able to do that now so
if i
type employee 1 for example
and then i type this dot you can see
that the only thing that we can access
is this introduce your introduce
yourself
method which is this one here and that
is the only thing that is public
besides this constructor here so
how can we access these properties then
well as i said we have to expose our own
methods which
are going to be public and then by using
those methods
other classes and other users will be
able to
interact with this data here with these
three properties
so let's create getters and setters for
these three properties
let's first do it for for our name
property
so i'm going to do it here uh let's say
void set name
and then what this method what this
function is going to receive
well that is going to be a string
name okay string like this
and then once this function receives
this
parameter called name what i want to do
with this is i want to assign this value
to this property here so i'm going to
say name
is equal to name okay
and then i want to create so this here
is a setter and then i want to create a
getter method as well so
i am going to say string get name
like this and then here i'm just going
to say return
name okay now
this method here receives one parameter
which is called
name and then it sets the value of
our property which is encapsulated which
is this one here
to that value that we have received in
this
setter and then this method here get
name
that method is going to return the value
of our name property that is also
encapsulated and that value is going to
be returned to whoever
invokes this method and because these
two methods
are public anyone outside of our class
is going to be able to invoke
set name and get name so these
are examples of setter and getter and
now i'm going to do the same for our
company property and age property and i
will be back to show you that code
in a moment so i have created getters
and setters for
our name property here so this is sether
this is getter for
our name property and then here is a
setter for our company and then
getter for company property and then
here are
setter and getter methods for age and
now because these methods here are
public everyone outside of our class
should be able to access these methods
whereas these three properties are now
encapsulated which means that they are
private they are hidden
within this class and no one else
besides
members of this class here are going to
be able to access them directly
so let's test now these getters and
setters in our main function
okay so let's say that employee 1
and let's say set age and i'm going to
say for example that my employee 1 now
has let's say 39
years for example okay
and in order to test these
gutters i'm going to say for example std
c out and then let's say
employee 1 dot
get name okay so our getter should work
like this and then let's say employee
one
is and i'm going to test if this value
has been
applied successfully so i'm going to say
employee one oh what is this
employee one dot get age
okay and here i want to say
employee one is 39
years old like this
okay and now if i run this program
we should get the result of this line
here and we should be able to see if our
getters and setters work as they should
so let's run our program
okay and now this last line of code here
says salina is 39 years old okay so
i shouldn't have done this for myself i
should have done this for john for
example
so i'm going to close this program and
as you could see
these get name and get age and also
get company and then set their methods
as well are now public
whereas the properties that they are
hiding are hidden within the class and
they are encapsulated
so the only way to access these three
properties is going to be using
these methods now what we can do with
these methods is we can provide
special rules to interact with this data
here
for example let's say that employee
cannot be anyone who is not
older than 18 years old so here
when actually here when i'm trying to
set the age of our employee i'm going to
add a check
so i'm going to add a validation rule
and i will say
if age age
this age that i have received in my
setter is
greater than 18 years old or actually
greater
or equal to than 18 because person that
has 18 years old is
of age only in the case that this
property here is greater than 18 years
old
only then i am going to assign that to
my age
property here in the case that our user
anyone else decides to assign value
which is less than 18 so 17 or 15 or 10
or whatever i am not going to apply
those changes so let's test this
also here instead of setting
age to 39 i'm going to say that salina
now is
15 so let's test those changes
okay and now as you can see it says
selena is 25 years old
why because this set age method here
says that only valid
age is 18 or greater than 18 and only in
that case
those changes are going to be applied
okay so you can apply certain
validation rules to your setter methods
and then i'm going to leave to you to
apply certain validation rules
to your set company name and then set
employee name this property here
so you can do that as a homework you can
decide if you want to allow
only letters or you want to allow also
numbers
and special characters as the name for
your employee and then
as the name for your company okay so
once more the idea of encapsulation is
to make this let me close this
so the idea of encapsulation is to make
these
properties private and then whoever
wants to access these properties
outside of this class will have to go
through the methods that you
expose that do have access to your
private
properties okay so let's collapse this
and here are those six
getters and setters for these three
properties here
the second principle that i want to talk
about is called abstraction
what is abstraction abstraction means
hiding
complex things behind a procedure that
makes those things look
simple so in order to explain this let's
use an
everyday life example let's use the
example of your smartphone
so one of the main characteristics that
smartphones have these days is that they
can take
pictures so how does that procedure of
taking a picture looks like
well it's pretty simple at least on your
side you just press
a button and you have taken a picture
where you press a button
and then you make a call or you send a
message but
that is not really that simple because
for you it is just
a button click but for the company that
makes those smartphones
there is much more complex logic that
they need to implement
in order for you to be able to press a
button and then
take a picture so there is some sort of
interface between you and then that
company that produces those smartphones
so
on your side everything is pretty simple
and easy you just press a button and you
make a call you press a button and you
send a message
but then all of that complexity behind
those functionalities
is hidden from you and that complexity
is on the side of the company that
produces those smartphones
now all of this complexity that is
hidden from you you don't actually need
to know
anything about this in order to be able
to use this site here in order to be
able to make calls
and send messages and take pictures
so what happens if another company comes
and they decide that they want to
produce smartphones as well
what they have to do is they have to
sign this contract here
they have to provide you as a user with
this
nice and beautiful and clean and simple
interface
so that you are able to press a button
and take a picture
and then they have to take care on their
side
to implement all of that complex
logic which is hidden from you because
if they decide to show you that
ugly side that complex side chances are
that no one is going to want to use
their smartphones at all
and even if someone decides that they do
want to use their smartphones
they will probably not understand this
complex logic well so that they will
so they will make mistakes and they will
use those smartphones in wrong
ways so this process of hiding that
complexity from you
as a user is called abstraction and in
that way
this very very complex system is hidden
and this system here is represented as
very simple
system by this contract so let's see how
we can implement
this contract here that makes one side
look simple and then other side
very complex let's implement that on the
code and example that we have here in
our visual studio
so let's take a look at this employee
class here
what kind of functionality complex
functionality can we
implement on this class here let's say
for example
that every employee can ask for
promotion
so he goes to his boss and he says hey
boss can i get a promotion
and then his boss needs to go through
this very
complex thought process in order to
decide if
this person deserves a promotion or not
so his boss needs to consider many
things he needs to consider
consider for example how long this
person has been working for the company
how much knowledge this person has
and then what kind of relationship this
person has with their colleagues how
much this person is contributing to the
company
um and then is this person always late
for work
are they breaking deadlines and many
many more things
so how about abstracting that
functionality
and in this situation we are doing that
for another developer that is going to
use our class so here in this situation
we are the ones who are making this
class so we are producing that
smartphone so we are the ones
who should provide that complex logic
for those
functionalities that are complex and
then we should provide that
simple and basic interface for anyone
who wants to use
this class here so how do you do that
how do you create
that contract well the answer is by
using
abstract classes for those of you who
are coming from
c sharp or java world there is already
this concept of
interface that some of you might be
familiar with and in c
plus plus you can simulate behavior of
interface
by using abstract class so let's create
an abstract class
so here on the top i am going to create
a class
and let's create a class called abstract
employee
like this or you can call it i
employee if you want so this class here
is going to serve as a contract
and this contract will have only one
rule and that rule is that whichever
class
decides to sign this contract that class
will need to provide
implementation for a method called ask
for promotion
so a method of return type void
called ask for promotion
like this and we are also going to make
this
obligatory which means that we will
force any class that
signs this contract here to implement
this method here so how can we make this
obligatory the answer is by making this
function here
a pure virtual function so i'm going to
say here
virtual and then
here i'm going to say is equal to zero
and now this class here has become an
abstract class
and this method here this function is
pure
virtual function or an abstract function
and this means that whoever decides to
sign this contract
called that abstractemployee.com
that signs this contract will have to
provide implementation for this
method here so now the question is how
can my class my employee class
sign this contract here the answer is
pretty simple
you add here column sign and then you
specify the name of your contract which
is
abstract employee like this
okay and now my class has successfully
signed
this contract and immediately if you
could notice
these two red dots that appeared below
if we hover over these errors because
these are errors you can see that it
says
pure virtual function abstract employee
ask for
promotion has no overrider
which means hey you signed this contract
here
but you are not obeying the rules of
that contract you are not
providing implementation for this
function here
so in order to avoid these errors and
fix these errors that we have now what
we have to do is we have to provide
implementation for this method here so
let's do that
okay i am going to copy it here and then
i will come here and paste it
and here in these curly brackets we are
going to
implement that method but as you could
see immediately the errors that we had
below have disappeared so here
inside this class i want to provide
logic
for ask for promotion method so once
more we said that that logic is pretty
complex and that we should take in
consideration many things
so things like how long that person has
been working for a company
how much that person is contributing to
the company what kind of relationship
they have
with their colleagues and so on but
considering that we don't have all of
that
information what i'm going to do is i'm
going to make it a little bit more
simple
so i'm going to say for example any
employee
that is older than 30 years old can get
a promotion
for example so i'm going to say here if
age is greater than 30.
i will do the following i will say std
see out and then let's write the name of
this employee i'm going to say name
and i'm going to say got promoted
like this okay
excellent and then in the else case
so in the case that person has less than
30 years i'm going to write something
else so i'm going to
deny that promotion to the person who is
younger than 30.
so i'm going to say name and then
let's write out sorry no promotion for
you
okay excellent and
now let's test this method here
so i'm going to go to my main function
and i
will delete all of this code here
okay and now i want to test
this method here on my employee 1 and
employee 2
so that i see if any of them can get
promotion
so let's say employee one dot
ask for promotion and then
employee two dot ask for promotion as
well
and if i run my program
it says salinas sorry no promotion for
you
and then john got promoted
and why that happened because let me
close this
because salina is 25 and then john is
35 and this rule here says that whoever
is older
than 30 which is john he gets promoted
and then
if that person is younger than 30 that
person is not going to be
promoted okay so with this we have
accomplished the following
we have implemented a contract which is
actually an abstract
class and that abstract class or that
contract has only
one rule and that rule is this pure
virtual function here which is called
ask for promotion so that means that
whichever class signs this contract
whichever class
inherits from this abstract employee
which is
this class here that class will have to
provide
implementation for this method here so
ask for
promotion so in this situation our
employee is
inheriting from our abstract employees
so our employee class
is signing that contract which means
that that class needs to provide
implementation for the method that is in
that
contract okay now what this allows us to
do
when another developer comes to our code
and wants to use our employee class
that developer will see this contract
here and he will say
oh so this employee class has method
which is called ask for promotion
so that means that if i use employee
class i can invoke this method here
and i don't need to worry about
complexity of this method i don't need
to worry
about how this promotion is given or
rejected
because that is the worry of the person
who implemented
this class here so that is the worry of
the person who is going to sign this
contract
and in this situation we are that person
we are the person who is
producing that smartphone we are the
person who is writing this class
and this class is signing the contract
which means that we have to provide
implementation for this
method here as we did in this situation
and we tested it and as you could see i
didn't get promotion
and john did so that is the idea of
abstraction
and this ask for promotion method is
just
that button that we mentioned a button
on your smartphone
from the beginning of this chapter the
third principle of object oriented
programming that i want to talk about
is called inheritance the idea of
inheritance is the following
so there is this base class also known
as
super class or parent class and then
there is
derived class also known as child class
or subclass now this base class here
this parent class has certain
attributes and behaviors it has members
and then if this class here decides to
inherit
from the base class at that moment this
class
becomes a child class and by that this
class is going to obtain
all of the members of this base class
here
which means this class is going to have
all the same
attributes and behaviors as its base
class
and then this derived class can also
have its own members that are specific
for that class only
which this class here does not have so
in order to explain this let's use an
example that is going to be familiar to
you
let's let's return to the example of a
car that i used
in the beginning of this video so a car
as a class is going to have certain
attributes
for example a name a model price
a color and so on and then it is going
to have behaviors as well for example it
has a method called
drive now what kind of derived classes
can we create from this
base class what kind of classes are more
specific
so what kind of car types are more
specific
than just car let's say for example that
we are going to have
one derived class that is called
electric car and then another derived
class which is called
conventional car or gas car now
this electric car is also going to have
all the same properties that a car has
so it is going to have
um it is going to have a name a model a
color a price
and then it is going to have a method
called drive and then this conventional
car is also going to have all those same
properties
but they are going to be different
between them this car for example
is going to have a method called charge
because this
is electric car and we need to use
electricity to charge it and then it is
going to have an attribute called
for example battery status and then this
car which is
gas car conventional car is going to
have a method called
think which means a method of putting
fuel
in that car and then it is going to have
a property an attribute
which is named tank status which shows
you how much
how much gas do you have left in your
tank so each one of these
derived classes is going to have their
specific attributes
but they will also inherit all of those
attributes that their base class
has so now let's see how we can
implement that on the example that we
have here
so here i have class called employee and
what i want to do is i want to create a
derived class for this class
here so what kind of class can inherit
from
employee class logically what is more
specific type of employee
let's say for example that we want to
create a class called
developer so let's do that here i'm
going to say class
and then let's call this class developer
like this okay so with this
we have created a class called developer
and now what i want to do
is i want to make this class inherit
from
this class here so how do you do that
the answer is pretty simple
you put column sign here and then you
specify the name of your base class and
the name is
employee so with this
a few things happened this class here
developer became
a child class which means a subclass or
divide
or derived class and then this class
here employee
is now called base class or super class
or
parent class and also another thing that
happened
is that this developer class here now
has
all of these properties and then these
ones here
as well that our employee class has
so developer has all of the properties
that employee has and then let's create
one more property that is going to be
specific for developer
only so i'm going to make that property
public
so here i'm not obeying the rules of
encapsulation you can do that for
homework for example
so let's create a property that only
developer has but
employee does not that is going to be
for example
favorite programming language developer
has favorite programming language but an
employee does not necessarily have to be
a developer
so he does not necessarily need to have
a favorite programming language so i'm
going to say
string favorite programming
language like this
i hope that i didn't make a typo here so
now let's check if everything that i
said is
correct so if this developer indeed has
access to all the properties that our
employee has
and then to this one here which is
specific for
developer only so let's delete
this code here and then i want to create
an
object of class developer so i'm going
to say developer
and let's call that object d like this
okay and the first thing that happens is
we get an
error and it says okay
it says default constructor of developer
cannot be
referenced so this error here is
happening
obviously because we don't have a
default constructor and if you remember
when we were talking about constructors
we said that
every class when you create it every
class has
automatically generated default
constructor
but once you decide to create your own
constructor you
lose that default constructor so now you
may ask
well selena we have not created
constructor for this developer class
and i'm going to say you're right but we
have inherited from
employee class and that employee class
has a constructor that we created so
that means that we need to provide a
constructor for the derived classes of
employee class which is our developer
class
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to create a constructor for developer
class
so if you remember three rules of
creating constructors
first rule is that it does not have
return type
second rule is that it has the same name
as the class
and then third rule is that it needs to
be
public so i'm going to call this
constructor developer
like this oh sorry
and then i need to put these curly
brackets here okay
so now the job of this constructor here
is going to be to construct
developer object and considering that
this developer object inherited from
employee class
that means that developer has
these properties so these attributes and
then this one which is
specific for only developer class so now
we have to
provide this constructor with those
parameters so i'm going to copy
these three here because i already have
them
and then paste them here and then i will
add this parameter which is specific for
developer class so i will say string
string language
like this so this is favorite
programming language or
actually let's call it favorite
programming language so that we are
consistent
okay now once we have passed
these four parameters to our developer
constructor
what we have to do is we have to
initialize this
attribute here and then these three
attributes here because those are
attributes that our
developer class has but one thing that i
want to show you is following
considering that this developer class is
inheriting from employee class
and that employee class has a
constructor of its own which is this one
here
that constructor already knows how to
construct
name and company at age so that means
that we don't have to worry about
these three properties in our developer
class we should only worry about
a specific properties of our developer
class and these three properties that
actually belong to our employee
we can pass these three to our employee
constructor
so i'm going to do that like this
here so after this parentheses
you put a column sign and then you
specify the name of that constructor so
employee so the name of your
base class and then here i will pass
these parameters that our base class
constructor
receives so name and then
company and age
okay so now this constructor the
constructor of our base class is going
to take care of
these three properties and we are left
with this property here which is
specific
for our developer class so here i want
to initialize
our favorite language property
so i'm going to say that favorite
language is equal to whatever
has been passed to this constructor
okay now if i go
down there to my main function where i
tried to create my developer
let's try to construct an object of type
developer let's try to invoke this
constructor here
like we did in this line here and then
in this line here for our
employee so i'm going to say that a
developer is going to be equal to
developer and then here i want to pass
values for this constructor here so
those are
name and company name and age and
favorite programming language
so let's call this developer also
salvina i'm going to delete these two
because we will not need them anymore
okay
and then let's say that i work for
youtube
code beauty and then
i am 25 years old and my favorite
programming language
is c plus plus for example
so now that i have successfully created
an object for developer class
let's test this so how am i going to
test this
well let's create a method on our
developer class that is going to use
some of these
values here so that we can know if these
values have indeed been set
successfully so what kind of method can
we
implement on developer class for example
we can implement a method called
fix bug so i'm going to do that let's
collapse this constructor and let's say
here void
fix bug
and then what i want this method here to
do is i wanted to say
selena is fixing bug using c
plus or selena fixed but using c plus
plus
so here i'm going to do that i'm going
to say std
c out and then in order to access the
name
of this employee i'm going to use getter
so i'm going to say
get name which we created previously
and then here i'm going to say fixed
bug using
and then let's use this programming
language here
like this okay and now if i want to test
this method here i can invoke it on my
developer class so i'm going to say d
dot fix bug and if i run my program
as you can see this method here works
and then
the values that we passed in our
constructor have successfully been set
so here it says selena
and then fixed bug using and then here
is my favorite programming language
okay let's close this and now there is
one more thing that i want to show you
and that is this part here so i want you
to notice
that this here is the way that we are
using
in order to access properties of our
employee class
and then we are accessing directly
properties of
our developer class so can i
access properties of my employee class
directly can i access
this property here for example name or
do i have to access it by using
getter write me your answers in the
comments down below
so i am going to test that now here i'm
going to save
name and we get an error it says
employee name is inaccessible so we
cannot
access this property here name which is
the property of
our employee class why well if you
remember when we were talking about
access modifiers we said that
whatever is private that is going to be
locked
hidden that is going to be accessible
only inside
that class and then whatever is public
we will be able to access that outside
of the class
so how can i make this property here
how can i make this name accessible in
the derived classes of this class
here again when we were talking about
access modifiers we said that there are
three of them
public private and protected and i
promised you that i am going to explain
what this
what protected access modifier means so
in this situation if we make this
property here
if we make this name property protected
that will make
name available in derived classes of
this employee class here so
i am going to say protected
like this and then i'm going to take
this property and i will move it to my
protected area
and then if i return to my developer
class
as you can see the error that we
previously had
is now gone so now this name property
is accessible directly from this derived
class here
and if i run the program it should work
the same as it did
and as you can see it indeed works the
same so selena fixed bug using
c plus okay now there is one more very
important thing
related to inheritance that i want to
show you and that is the following
let's say for example that this
developer here fixes a lot of bugs
so if i run my program you can see that
salvina indeed is fixing a lot of bugs
so what this developer here decides then
is he or she in this situation she
decides to ask
for promotion so i'm going to try to do
that now i'm going to say d
dot but if you look at the list
that i have here it only has the access
to favorite programming language and
then
fix bug so if you look at this you can
see that i don't have access to the
other properties
that i have inherited from my employee
class
i do have access to them here so if i
try to invoke them
in this method here so if i say here for
example
ask for promotion as you can see i do
have access to them here
but as you could see on my developer
object i cannot
access those properties so how can i fix
that problem
well the answer is pretty simple this
inheritance here so this part of the
code here
this inheritance is private by default
and in order to fix the problem that we
have
we need to make it public so here i'm
going to say
public and the problem should
disappear so if i return to my developer
object now
and if i try to ask for promotion as you
can see
that method is available so
maybe i'll get a promotion this time
let's test
this and unfortunately i am not
getting a promotion but at least my code
is working so
now we have access to this method here
which is implemented in my
employee class so in my base class and
we have achieved that
by making this inheritance public
so while we are talking about
inheritance let's create one more class
that is going to inherit from this
employee class so let's create one more
derived class
besides this developer so what kind of
class can inherit from employee what is
more specific
class than employee for example let's
create a class called
teacher so here i'm going to go one more
time through this process of creating
derived class so i will say
class and then i will call it teacher
like this okay and with this
we have successfully created a class
called teacher
and now what i want to do is i want to
inherit
from my employee class
like this okay and then what i need to
do
is let's first create some specific
attributes for my teacher so let's say
for example that a teacher
has attribute called subject
so this here is the subject that my
teacher is teaching
and then let's say also that the teacher
will have
a functionality that is going to be
specific for this class only
and that functionality will be called
prepare
lesson for example so i'm going to say
void
prepare lesson
like this okay
and what i want to do here is i want to
do something like this so i want to say
for example the name of that teacher and
then i won't say that
he or she is preparing lesson from this
subject here so let's delete this
empty space so i'm going to say std
c out and then let's put the name of my
teacher so name like this
and then let's say is
preparing and then here i want to put
the name of my subject like this
and then let's add lesson
okay now there are a few problems
that we have with this class here the
first problem is that
these here are private which means that
we will not be able to access them
outside of this class here because
everything inside the class
is private by default so that is going
to be the first problem
and let's fix it so i'm going to say
public
like this okay now second thing that is
going to be a problem for us is that
this teacher class here does not have a
constructor
so if i try to create an object of type
teacher i will not be able to do that so
let's demonstrate that
error now i'm going to say teacher
like this and let's call it t and well
if i do this only we should get an error
which says
default constructor of teacher cannot be
referenced
which means that we need to implement a
constructor for this class here
as we did for this class here so as we
did for our developer class so let's do
that
i am going to create a constructor
called
teacher
like this and then this teacher
constructor
will receive these three properties that
our employee has
like this and then it will receive
another
parameter called subject
subject okay now
this constructor is going to pass these
three properties
to constructor of base class so this one
here
let's do that let's say
let's say here employee and then
inside i will pass name and company
and age and then here this teacher class
will take care of constructing
this part so i'm going to say that my
subject
is equal to this subject that we
received in our constructor
okay and now if i return down here
and i try to make a teacher
let's name the teacher jack for example
and he is going to work in a school
called
cool school if such thing exists
okay and then he's going to be 35 years
old
and he is going to be history teacher
for example okay
now we have successfully created our
teacher
jack and i am going to collapse this
and then i want to test this method here
so i'm going to say
teacher t dot and then prepare lesson
okay and if i run this program
it says that jack is preparing history
lesson okay and then one more problem
that we have with this class here is
that our
teacher t does not have access to
properties of our employee class so
if i type t dot as you can see it has
access only to these two properties so
in order to fix that problem i am going
to add
public here okay and if
i try to make jack ask for promotion
let's see if jack gets the promotion
because
i didn't get promotion okay it says jack
got promoted excellent and i didn't and
that is because jack is
35 years old and i am 25 years old
okay so if you don't know what i'm
talking about you will have to return
to the part where we are talking about
um encapsulation i believe okay
so that was the story of inheritance we
created
two derived classes one is developer and
the other one is teacher
and those two classes are inheriting
from a class called
employee as you can see here and here
and we will be using these classes in
our next
example to explain our next concept
which is
polymorphism as i said fourth principle
of object-oriented programming is called
polymorphism and this is the one that i
see people struggle with the
most for some reason i don't know why
because it is pretty
simple and cool as you will see so it is
very simple but
only if you understand the things that i
have explained so far in this course
so the first thing that i want to
explain is what is
polymorphism uh the word itself comes
from greek language and it is a compound
of poly
and morph which means many forms
and in programming polymorphism
describes the ability
of an object or a method to have many
forms now the most common use of
polymorphism in programming
is when a parent class reference is used
to refer to an
object of a child class does that sound
a little bit complex when i say it like
that
i believe that it does and i agree but
stick with me for a couple of minutes
and let me show you how simple this
really is
on the example that we have here so in
order to explain how polymorphism works
let's return to our employee class so
this one here i'm going to collapse this
and then what i want to do in my
employee class is i want to implement
one more
method and let's call that method work
so i'm going to say
void work
and then here in this method what i want
to do
is i want to say for example
out um let's say name of this
employee and then let's say that that
employee
is checking email
and then he is checking also task
backlog
okay it's backglog okay
task backlog and then he is performing
those tasks
and so on okay and let's add end line
like this okay now
let's return to this main function here
and what i want to do is i want to
invoke
that new work method that i just
implemented
and i want to invoke that method on this
developer and
teacher class because considering the
developer and teacher are inheriting
from that employee class
we should be able to do that so if i say
d dot work
and then t dot work
let's see what will we get if i run this
program
okay it says here selena is checking
email
task backlog performing tasks and so on
and then jack is also checking email
task backlog and performing those tasks
but one thing that i don't like is i
don't like me checking
emails and checking task backlog and so
on
what i like is i like to write code so
how about implementing this work method
on my developer class as well
so let's return here to my developer
class
and what i want to do here is i want to
copy this
method like this but
instead of checking email and checking
task backlog and so
on what i want to do here is i want to
say
that i am writing code so let's say
salina is
writing and then let's put this
programming language here
like this and then let's say
code okay and now i'm going to do the
same for this
teacher class here so let's copy this
method
and then paste it in my teacher class
but instead of writing code teacher is
going to be doing something else
so what teacher does well teacher
teaches
so i'm going to say the name of my
teacher which is
jack in this situation so jack
is teaching
and then let's put the name of his
subject
which is history i believe okay
now one thing that you must notice is
that this
work method has the same name here
and then here as well and it also has
the same name
in this base class so it is called work
but the implementations of this method
this work method
are different here it says that an
employee is checking an
email and checking task backlog and so
on
and then developer has also its own
implementation which says that developer
is
writing code because that is his work
and then teacher is teaching his
subject which is his job so
i have here invoked these two work
methods
and let's see what will happen if i run
my program now
okay now it is better it says that
salvina is writing c
plus code and jack is teaching history
okay now let's make one small
improvement to the code that we have
here
or actually two improvements and the
first one is going to be this
writing with double t okay what is this
this is criminal
and then the second one is going to be
the rule that i mentioned in the
beginning
when i said the most common use of
polymorphism
so let me copy that definition here and
then we will implement it
literally word by word so here it is
and it says the most common use of
polymorphism is
when a parent class reference is used to
refer
to a child class object so let's see
what this means in practice i'm going to
delete
these two lines because i don't need
them anymore
and then what i want to do is i want to
create a pointer of type
employee
like this and one quick disclaimer if
you are not familiar with pointers
i am going to refer you to my channel
which is code beauty with where i have
an entire playlist which is dedicated to
pointers so make sure to watch that and
then you can continue
with this example here so again
i have created an employee pointer
and what i want to assign to this
pointer is not going to be an
employee object so i want to assign to
this
pointer here a reference of this
developer and then this
teacher class so here i'm going to say
you are going to hold
a reference to this developer here
and this here is the rule so a pointer
of base class
which is this here can hold
reference to derive class object which
is
this part here so so that is just the
rule
why well because this developer here
this developer is deep down inside it is
an employee because developer is
inheriting from
employee as we already could see in the
previous examples of this
course so now that i have done this
let's do the same for our teacher so
i'm going to copy this line and then
here i'm going to name this
employee 1 and then this is going to be
my employee 2
and here i will say that employee 2 will
hold
the reference of my teacher here
so now what i want to do and what i want
to achieve with this
is the following wouldn't it be nice if
i could do something like this
so employee one dot work
okay and then employee two
dot work and this
symbol here is used when you want to
access
members using a pointer so instead of
dot symbol when you use a pointer you
use this symbol here
okay so wouldn't it be nice if this here
worked
well let's see maybe it does if i run my
program
as you can see it again says alina is
checking email
and task backlog and performing tasks
and so on and jack is doing the same and
he's a teacher and i'm developer
so that means that this here does not
work
but if you only knew how close we are to
making this work
you are literally missing only one tiny
little thing that i didn't tell you
to make this here work so
what that thing is well let's return to
our
employee class and then here
this work method let's make this work
method
virtual so i'm going to say virtual
here so let's run our program now
and as you can see it says saudina is
writing c
plus code and jack is teaching history
so
it works wait i have to explain this
okay so let's return to our employee
class
to explain what just happened well
look at this function here this virtual
void function
this function with this virtual keyword
is known as virtual
function and what that means well it
means that
when a virtual function is invoked it
says
hey can you please check if there is
implementation of this function
in my derived classes and if yes please
execute that instead so what ends up
happening
is that the most derived version of this
function here is going to be
executed and that is this function here
for developer and then
this function here for teacher
so does that mean that if we didn't for
example have
implementation of function called work
in our developer
that our developer then would do this
that our employee has in its
work function the answer is yes so let
me comment this
just to demonstrate how it would behave
so now i commented implementation of
work function in my
developer class so if i run the program
now
as you can see it says salina is
checking
email and task backlog and performing
some random tasks
and then jack is teaching and this is
happening because
teacher class has its own implementation
of
work method work function but developer
class
does not so here developer is going to
execute
parents class method work which is this
method here so that's why i am checking
email and task backlog and performing
random
tasks instead of writing c plus
code so let's close this and let's now
return this
i'm going to uncomment it like this
and let's run my program once more and
as you can see
everything works again and we have this
polymorphic behavior
so that ladies and gentlemen is
polymorphism
so let me give you one little tip of
what we can do with this knowledge now
so let's close this
and i'm going to return to my main
function and
here as you can see here we are creating
a base class pointer to a derived class
object which is in the situation
developer and then
in this situation it is teacher and then
in some other situation it can be
some other type of employee so if we
created more derived classes which we
could do we could create for example
derived class called bus driver or pilot
or singer or
actor doctor and so on and then
we could keep objects of those derived
classes like this
so we could reference them with this
base class
pointer because they would derive from
employee as well
and then imagine situation where you had
100 or
thousand or even 10 000 employees
and then you are storing those like this
like we did with our developer and
our teacher and then you could literally
in one line
say employee dot work and what would
happen is that
all of those different types of
employees would start
doing their own job so painters would
paint singers would sing
actors would act doctors would talk with
patients or something
i don't know so that is the most
beautiful thing that we have
achieved with this here so i hope that
you enjoyed this video
if you did give it a thumbs up and then
also if you want more videos like this
one
you can visit my channel which is code
beauty and there i have a lot of
videos related to programming and c plus
and also leave me a comment i would love
to read something like hey
i am coming from precode camp or
something like that on one of my videos
so thank you very much for watching and
i'm going to see you in some next video
on this channel and then
if you decide to visit code beauty
youtube channel i will definitely see
you in one
of my videos bye
so now i'm going to take a break for a
couple of hours but for you it is going
to be just a couple of seconds because
i'm going to pause the video here
and for this i want to try a transition
that i never did before
and it is this one
so what is polymorphism the word
polymorphism comes from latin language
and it means or is it greek
2 000 years later
i'm just going to skip this information
so if i hover over this as you can see
we still have an
error but we have a different error
which means that we are making progress
also visit me on my channel which is
code beauty and subscribe there
and also leave me a comment i would love
to read something like hey selena i am
coming from free code camp
and your course was great or hey salina
i am coming from free code camp and your
course was
excellent or perfect or outstanding or
something like that
you know